I have very strong memories of the
argument Missile Crisis and of those 13
days
when we came closer to nuclear war you
know and particularly I think it was
when the U2 got shot down over
uh Cuba had you know and nobody in this
guy there's a lot of people in
Washington DC who at that point thought
that they very male it may well may wake
up dead
that the world may end at night 30
million Americans killed 130 million
Russians
this is what our military brass wanted
they saw a war with Russia nuclear
exchange with Russia as not only
inevitable but also desirable because
they wanted to do it now
oh we still had a superiority can you
actually go through the feelings you've
had about the Cuban Missile Crisis like
what what are your memories of it what
are some interesting I know in the
middle I was going to school in
Washington DC to
um or to um
Our Lady of Victory which is in
Washington DC so we were I lived in
Virginia across Atomic and we would
cross the bridge every day into DC
and during the crisis uh U.S Marshals
came to my house
to take us I think around day eight
my father was spending the night at the
White House he wasn't coming home he was
staying with the XCOM committee and
sleeping there and they were up you know
24 hours they were debating and fake
trying to figure out what was happening
and
um but we had U.S Marshals come to our
house to take us down they were going to
take us down to um a White Sulfur
Springs
and uh in Southern Virginia in the in
the Blue Ridge Mountains where there was
a
um there was an underground city
essentially a bunker that was like a
city and apparently it had McDonald's in
it and a lot of other you know it had it
was a full City for the U.S government
and their families
U.S Marshals came to our house to take
us down there and I was very excited
about doing that and this was at a time
you know when we were doing the drills
we were doing the ducking cover drills
um once a week at our school
or they would tell you if they that you
know when the alarms go off
um then you you put your head onto the
table you take the remove the Sharps
from your desk
put them inside your desk you put your
head onto the table and you wait and the
ignition blast will take the windows out
of the school and then we all stand up
and and file in an orderly fashion into
the basement where we're going to be for
the next six or eight months or whatever
but in the basement where you know we we
win occasionally in those corridors
were lined with uh freeze-dried food
canisters off to this here from Florida
ceiling so people were you know we were
all preparing for this and it was you
know uh Bob McNamara who is my it was a
friend of mine and you know it was my
father one of my father's close friend
as Secretary of Defense
he later called Mass psychosis and my
father deeply regretted participating in
the bomb shelter program because he said
it was part of a a you know a
psychological psyop trick
to treat them to teach Americans that
nuclear war was acceptable
that it was survivable my father anyway
when they when the marshals came to our
house to take me and my brother Joe away
and we were the ones who are home at
that time yeah
um my father called and he talked to us
on the phone and he said
I don't want you going down there
because
um
because if you disappear from school
people are gonna panic
and I need you to be a good soldier and
go to the school now and and he said
something to me during that period which
was that if the nuclear war happened it
would be better to be among the dead
than the living which I did not believe
okay I mean I I had already prepared
myself for the you know for the for the
dystopian future and I knew I could I
spent every day in the woods I knew that
I could survive by catching crawfish and
you know cooking mud puppies and we'll
do whatever I had to do but I felt like
okay I can I could handle this uh
and I really wanted to see the setup
down in you know this underground city
but anyway that was you know part of it
for
um me my father was away and you know
the last days of it
my father
um got this idea because Khrushchev had
sent two letters
he sent one letter that was conciliatory
and then he sent a letter that after his
Joint Chiefs and the warmongers around
him saw that letter and they disapproved
of it they sent another letter that was
extremely belligerent
and my father had the idea let's just
pretend we didn't get the second letter
and reply to the first one
and then he went down to dobrennan
and who was he met the Brennan in the
justice department and the Brennan was
the Soviet Ambassador and they you know
they proposed this settlement which was
a secret settlement
Eric Khrushchev would withdraw the
missiles from Cuba Khrushchev had put
them into Cuba because we had put
missiles you know nuclear missiles in in
turkey and
Italy and my uncle's secret deal was
that if he if Khrushchev removed the
missiles from Cuba within six months he
would get rid of the Jupiter missiles in
Turkey but if Khrushchev told anybody
about the deal it was off so if if news
got out about that secret deal it was
off that was the actual deal and
Khrushchev complied with it and then my
uncle complied with it how much of that
part of human history turned on the
decisions of one person
I think that's one of the you know
because that of course the perennial
question right but it is history kind of
on uh
an automatic pilot and you know uh human
decisions the decisions of leaders
really only have you know a marginal or
incremental bearing on what is going to
happen anyway but I think that is the
and historians argue about that all the
time
I think that that is a really good
example of a play a a place in human
history that uh literally the world
could have ended if
we had a different leader in the White
House and the reason for that is that
there were as I recall 64 gun
emplacements you know missile missile
emplacements
each one of those Muslim placements had
a crew of about 100 men
and they were Soviets
so
um they were and they we didn't know
whether we had a couple of questions
that my uncle asked
Alan or ask the CIA and he asked Dulles
was already gone but he asked the CIA
and he asked um his military brass
because they all wanted to go in
everybody wanted to go ahead and my
uncle said my uncle asked to see the
aerial photos and he examined those
personally and that's why it's important
to have a leader in the White House who
can push back on on their bureaucracies
he
um and then he asked them
you know are those who's Manning those
missile sites and are they Russians and
if they're Russians and we bomb them
uh are they isn't it going to force
Khrushchev to then go into Berlin
and that would be the beginning of a
Cascade effect that would you know
highly like the nuclear confrontation
and the the uh the military perhaps said
to my uncle oh we don't think you'll
have uh you know we don't think he'll
have the uh the guts to do that so he
was my uncle was like that's what you're
betting on
and uh you know they all wanted him to
go in they wanted him to bomb the sides
and then invade Cuba and he said if we
bomb those sites we're going to be
killing Russians and it's going to force
it's going to provoke Russia into some
response and the obvious response is for
them to go into Berlin
oh the but the thing that we didn't know
then that we didn't find out until I
think uh you know there was a it was
like a 30-year anniversary of the Cuban
Missile Crisis in Havana
and what we learned then was that from
the Russians who came
to that event it was like a symposium
where everybody on both sides talked
about it and we learned a lot of stuff
and and never nobody knew before
one of the insane things the most insane
thing that we learned was that the the
weapons were already the nuclear
warheads were already in place they were
ready to fire
and that the authorization to fire
was made was delegated to each of the
gun gun crew commanders so there were 60
people
who had all had authorization of fire if
they felt themselves under attack
so you have to believe that at least one
of them would have launched and that
would have been the beginning of the end
and you know if they if anybody had
launched you know we knew what would
happen my uncle knew what would happen
because he asked again and again what's
going to happen and they said 30 million
Americans will be killed
but we will kill 130 million Russians so
we will win and that was a victory for
them
and my uncle said later said he talked
he told Arthur Schlesinger and Kenny
O'Donnell he said those guys he called
them the salad brass the guys with all
of this stuff on their chest
and he said he said those guys they
don't care
because they know that if it happens
that they're going to be in the charge
of everything they're the ones who are
going to be running the world after that
so for them you know it was it was an
incentive to to kill 130 million
Russians and 30 million Americans but my
uncle he had this correspondence with
the Khrushchev
they were secretly corresponding with
each other and that is what saved the
world is that they had that both of them
had been Men of War
Eisenhower famously said it will it will
not be a man of war
will not be a soldier who starts world
war three because a guy who's actually
seen it knows how bad it is and my uncle
you know had been In the Heat of the
South Pacific
he's already been cut into by a Japanese
Destroyer
um his many three of his crewmen have
been killed one of them badly burned he
he pulled that guy with a lanyard in his
teeth
six miles to an island in the middle of
the night and then they hid out there
for 10 days you know and
um and you know he came back like I said
he was the only uh president of the
United States that are in the Purple
Heart
um meanwhile crew Chef had been a
Stalingrad which was the worst place to
be on the planet you know probably in
the 20th century other than you know and
Al Switzerland one of the death camps
it was uh you know it was it was the
most ferocious horrific war with people
starving people you know committing
cannibalism uh you know eating the dogs
the cats eating their shoe leather
we're easing to death by the thousands
Etc
a cruise ship did not want the last
thing he wanted was a war and the last
thing my uncle wanted was a reward and
they but the CIA did not know anything
about Khrushchev and the reason for that
is the city there was a mole at Langley
so that every time the CIA got a spy
in the Kremlin he would immediately be
killed
so if they had no eyes in the Kremlin
you know there were literally hundreds
of Russia of Russian spies Who had who
were defected the United States and were
in the Kremlin who were killed during
that period
they had no idea anything about
Khrushchev about how he saw the world
and they saw the Kremlin itself as a
monolith you know that it is uh there's
kind of you know the same way that we
look at Putin today that you know it's
all they have this ambition of world
conquest and that's it's driving them
and there's nothing else they think
about there are absolutely single-minded
about it
but actually there was a big division
between Khrushchev and uh and his Joint
Chiefs and his intelligent apparatus and
they and they both at one point
discovered they were both in the same
situation they were surrounded by spies
and military personnel who were intent
on going to war and they were the two
guys resisting it so when my uncle my
uncle had this idea of you know being
the peace president
from the beginning he told Ben Bradley
his one of his best friends who you know
was around the publisher of the
Washington Post
for the editor-in-chief at that time he
said um
Ben Bradley asked him what is what do
you want in your gravestone and my uncle
said he kept the peace
he said
the principal job of the president of
the United States is to keep the country
out of War
and um and
so when he first became president he he
actually agreed
to meet Khrushchev in Geneva to his
Summit and by the way Eisenhower had
wanted to do the same thing Eisenhower
wanted peace but his and he was going to
meet in Vienna
but that peace Summit was blown up he
was going to try to do
um
you know he was going to try to end the
Cold War Eisenhower was in the last year
of his of his in May of 1960.
but that was torpedoed by the CIA during
the U2 crash you know they sent a
YouTube over the over the Soviet Union
and it got shot down and then they told
and then Alan told us
old Eisenhower to deny that we hit a
program they didn't know that the
Russians had captured Gary Francis
powers
and so when and and that blew up the
piece talks between Eisenhower and
Khrushchev and so you know they and the
the uh there was a lot of tension
my uncle wanted to break that tension he
agreed to meet with
um
with Khrushchev in Vienna early on in
his term
he went over there and Khrushchev
snobbed him
khrushchev's lectured him imperiously
about the you know the
the terror of American imperialism and
and rebuffed any you know they did agree
not to go into Laos they made an
agreement that kept the United States
became my uncle from sending troops to
Laos
but
um it had been a disaster Vienna so then
we had a spy that used to come to our
house all the time I cut Georgie
ballshank away he was this Russian
spy my my parents had met at the embassy
they had gone to a party or a reception
that Russian Embassy and he had
approached them and they knew he was he
was a GRU agent and KGB he was both
oh he used to come to our house they
really liked him he was very attractive
he was always laughing and joking he
would do rope climbing contests with my
father he would do push-up contests with
my father he was he could do the Russian
dancing the Cossack dancing
and he would do that for us and teach us
that and he was and we knew he was a spy
too and this was at the time of you know
the James Bond films were first coming
out so it was really exciting for us to
have an actual Russian spy in our house
the state department was horrified by it
but um but anyway
when Khrushchev after Vienna
and after
um you know the pigs
on Khrushchev had second thoughts
and he sent this long letter to my uncle
and he didn't want to go through his in
his State Department
or his Embassy he wanted to Enron them
and he was friends with [__]
so he gave Georgie the letter and
Georgie brought it and handed it to
Pierre Salinger folded in the New York
Times
and he gave it to my uncle and it was
this beautiful letter which he said
you know
um he my uncle had talked to him about
the children who were played you know we
played 29 grandchildren who were playing
in his yard and he's saying what is our
moral basis for making a decision that
could kill these children so they'll
never write a poem they'll never
participate in election they'll never
run for office how can we make it how
can we can we morally make a decision
that is going to eliminate
life of these beautiful kids
and um he had said that to to Khrushchev
and Khrushchev wrote in this letter back
saying that he was now sitting as this
dacha
on the Black Sea and
um that he was thinking about what my
uncle jacket said to him at Vienna and
he regretted very deeply not having
taken the olive leaf
that jacket offered him and then he said
you know it occurs to me now that we're
all on an arc and that there is not
another one and that the entire fate of
the planet
and all of its creatures and all of the
children are dependent on the decisions
we make and you and I have a moral
obligation to go forward with each
other's friends
and immediately after that this was you
know he sent that right after the Berlin
crisis in 1962
General Curtis LeMay
um tried to
um had tried to provoke a war
with a an incident at Checkpoint Charlie
which was the the the entrance the
entrance exit through the Berlin Wall in
Berlin and the Russian tanks has come to
the wall the U.S tanks have gone to the
wall and there was a standoff
and my uncle had had uh sent a message
to Khrushchev then through dobren and
saying my back is at the wall I cannot I
have no place to back to please back off
and then we will back off and cruise
shaft took his word
packed his Tanks off first and then my
uncle ordered lemayed it back back Ian
Lemay had mounted bulldozer plows on the
on the front of the tanks to to plow
down the Berlin wall and that and the
Russian sitcom so it was just you know
it was the right it was his generals
trying to provoke a war
and I'm
but they started talking to each other
then and then when he after he wrote
that letter they agreed that they would
install a hotline
so they could talk to each other and
they wouldn't have to go through
intermediaries and so at Jack's house on
the cape
there was a red phone that we knew if we
pick it up cruise Shuffle dancer
and there was another one in the white
house yeah
and but they knew it was important to
talk to each other you know and you just
wish that we had that kind of leadership
today
I can I you know it just understands our
job
look I know you know a lot about AI
right and you know how dangerous it is
potentially to humanity and what
opportunity is it also
um you know offers
but
it could kill us all I mean Elon said
first is going to steal our job and it's
going to kill us right yeah and it's
it's probably not hyperbole it's
actually you know if it follows the loss
of biological evolution which are just
the laws of mathematics that's probably
a good end point for it you know a a
potential endpoint
so
um we we need it's going to happen
but we need to make sure it's regulated
and it's regulated properly for safety
in every country and and that includes
Russia and China and Iran
right now we we should be putting all
the weapons of war aside and sitting
down with us guys and saying how are we
doing how are we going to do this
there's much more important things to do
we're gonna this stuff is gonna kill us
if we don't figure out how to regulate
it
and and Leadership needs to look down
the road at what what is the real risk
here and the real risk is that you know
AI will it will you know enslave us for
one thing
and you know and and then destroy us and
do all this other stuff and how about
biological weapons
we're now all working on these
biological weapons and we're doing
biological weapons from
foreign
weapons that can only kill Russians
the Chinese are making that you know are
can kill people who don't who don't have
Chinese genes
so all of this isn't out within reach
we're actively doing it
and we need to stop it and we can easily
a biological weapons treaty is the
easiest thing in the world to do
we can verify it we can enforce it and
everybody wants to agree to it it only
insane people do not want about want to
continue this kind of research there's
no reason to do it
so there's these existential threats to
all of humanity now out there like AI
biological weapons we need to start stop
fighting each other
start competing on economic game fields
Playing Fields instead of military
playing fields
which will be good for all of humanity
and that we need to sit down with each
other
and negotiate reasonable treaties on how
we regulate Ai and biological weapons
and nobody's talking about this in this
political race right now nobody's
talking about it in a government
they get fixated on these little Wars
and you know and uh these comic book
depictions of good versus evil and you
know and we all go you know uh and and
go off to and give them the weapons and
enrich
you know the military complex but we're
we're on the Road to Perdition if we
don't end this and some of this requires
to have this kind of
phone that connects Khrushchev and John
F Kennedy that cuts through all the
bureaucracy to have this communication
between heads of state and in the in the
case of AI perhaps heads of tech
companies where you can just pick up the
phone and have a conversation because a
lot of it a lot of the existential
threats of artificial intelligence
perhaps even bio weapons is
unintentional
it's not even uh strategic it's actual
effects so you have to be transparent
and honest about especially with AI that
people might not know
what what's the worst that's going to
happen once you release it out into the
wild and you have to have an honest kind
of communication about how to do it so
that companies are not terrified of
Regulation
uh overreach regulation and then
government is not terrified of tech
companies of um manipulating them in
some director and direct ways so like
there's a trust that builds versus a
distrust
that that seems to so basically that old
phone or Khrushchev can call
John F Kennedy is needed
yeah and you know I don't think there's
listen I don't understand AI okay I do
know I I can see from all this
technology how
it's this kind of turn keto
totalitarianism that once you put these
systems in place you know they can be
misused to enslave people and they can
be misused in wars and you know to
subjugate the kill to do all of these
bad things
and I don't think there's anybody on
Capitol Hill who understands this you
know we need to bring in the tech
community and say tell us what these
regulations need to look like you know
so that there can be freedom to innovate
so that we can
milk AI for all of the good things but
not you know fall into these traps that
are gonna you know that that are these
existential threats to that pose
existential threats to humanity